Vậy Việt đã qua vũ tàu tiếp nhận hàng chục trường hợp đau bụng nôn nói,
nguyên sông ũ được thực phẩm sau khi ăn bánh mì tại một cơ sở kinh roanh trên địa bản phường vũ tàu.
Sáng ũ bũn hàng ba, bệ vệ đã qua vũ tàu cho biết đang tiếp tục điều chỉ cho các bạn nhân
nguyên ngộ được thực phẩm, liên quan đến việc ăn bánh mì tại một tiệm trên đường lồ chiều.
Theo thương tiên cập nhật đến bây giờ cùng ngày, bệnh vệnh đã tiếp nhận ngâm mì từ ca,
với các trở chúng chủ yếu như đau bụng, buồn nôn, nôn nói, một số trường hợp mệt mất nước sò nôn nhiều.
Các bạn nhìn cho biết, trước đó đã ăn bánh mì tại cơ sở ở số mùi bà đồ chiều.
Thương được gọi là bánh mì không tin, zò không chào bằng hiểu.
Chiumu bà tháng ba, bị bán nhân dân phương vũ tàu, thành lập đoàn kìm tra đồ sớt cơ sở này,
tại thơ điểm làm việc, chủ cơ sở cho biết, chiumu hai tháng ba đã bán khoảng 1,5 mấy mì.
Đóng kìm tra khi nhận khu vực bán hàng và nơi xơ triếp thức phẩm ở hại để điểm khác nhau.
Cơ sở sở chính giải phép kinh doanh và dễ chính giản liên quan, sau chơi trình măng được môn góc một số mùi nhiều.
Lựa chức năng đã lấy mẫu thức phẩm để sẽ nhẹm, đồng thời yêu cầu tạm nương họt đồng, cho kết lộn chính thức.